qu'est-ce que tu es venu [ __ ] ici
tu vois je suis venu voir mon cancer
c'est maintenant qu'il vient juste de
sortir
non c'est une semaine qui sortait
cya on a parlé
c'est quoi votre engouement pour les
marocains s'est dit quelque chose allait
bentalha et sa clique
je suis pas une balance tu cherches quoi
hein je vous retourne et hop la terre
c'est ça que tu veux
je veux tout retombe date acide et que
tous tes oreilles des yeux et d'autre du
cul je veux tout savoir
tous ces changements mais qui s'appelle
la ligue marocaine je peste entendu
parler de lui tu parles trop et bakary
les déserts bouche des sièges quand on
fait attention au matériel musical tadu
aurait pu faire n'importe quoi ce que
des petites merdes
oui talent qu'elle tombe cette semaine
partout
je peux faire contre ça
et c'est bon je peux le tape alors vous
mâcher les coûts ne sais pas ce que tu
faisais des [ __ ]
son match à rabat